[Music]
if you support Donald Trump or his ban
on travel from seven countries let me
ask you a few questions I'm not going to
yell not going to question policy just a
couple questions where is this beautiful
little one from what is her nationality
do you think where does her extended
family live what kind of threat could
she be to you and what would you do to
save her life what is your religion tell
you to do about her what do your
instincts tell you to do about her what
do your experiences with children of
your own tell you what to do about here
what do your experiences of loss tell
you to do
what kinda again if when you die no
matter your religion your idea of an
afterlife is even remotely accurate what
happens if you are judged by what you
did or what you would have done about
her because she of course is all the
children in the world she of course is
all the innocence in the world she has a
name obviously she is Fatima and she is
nearly five months old and two of her
grandparents live near Portland Oregon
two of them are citizens of the United
States of America and she has a heart
condition and she needs surgery and she
and her parents live in Iran but they
were on their way to Portland because
open-heart surgery on an infant is
always a mortal risk and frankly her
mother and father and her grandparents
the American citizens the proud American
grandparents they all agreed our country
is simply better at open-heart surgery
for kids than is Iran they had filled
out every document they are not indigent
they asked no financial help the family
here the American citizen grandparents
and her American citizen uncle who is
literally named Uncle Sam they were
planning to pay it's not a transplant
helping Fatima does not mean not helping
an american-born child the family was
leaving Iran to go to the Oregon Health
and Science University Hospital in
Portland just as the Trump band was
being announced that's when the US
consulate in Dubai cancelled their visa
appointment
because we're not supposedly letting
anybody in from Iran not even if their
grandparents are citizens not even if
they need surgery to live not even if
they are four months old her uncle said
they were told to apply again in 90 days
her uncle said he wasn't sure if atom a
had that long is this who you want us to
be this decision was made in your name
this decision to hell with you fat ma
you're from Iran try again in three
months if you're still alive do we have
to be cruel is that what you want
whatever your fears or your concerns
whatever you think of this man trump
Padme was banned in your name and mine
luckily for you and me a week into this
nightmare politicians swarmed this case
and Fatima and her family now reported
we have a waiver to come here regardless
to save her life
but how many other fat amaze are there
among the 60,000 or more who had their
visas revoked and how many more might
there yet be when you meet your maker
and you say how pro-life you were and
patriotic and a faithful member of your
church what are you going to say when he
then asks great what did you do about
Fatima and all the other fat amazed